I want to jump to the story from the New
York Post RFK Jr comes out in favor of
reparations carving out lane to Biden's
left a bunch of stories come out at the
same time saying that new poll shows
that Donald Trump will lose votes to RFK
Jr if he runs as an independent if it
comes to the general I think that's
absurd nonsense now we're seeing the
story that RFK Jr is favoring
reparations I don't see Trump supporters
voting for a guy who this is the track
that he's on I see the progressive left
and Democrats who don't like Jo Biden
because he's too old voting for RFK Jr
but Scott you're you're deeply in
trenching this stuff what do you think
no this is this is baloney anyone that
tells you that Trump's supporters are
going to vote for RFK or he's going to
pull over that middleman no here's the
difference and look I want to make it
clear I'm not endorsing this
presidential race I am staying neutral
I'm focused on making Joe Biden a
one-term president but the fact of the
matter is people didn't vote for Joe
Biden out of love they voted him because
they didn't like the other option Trump
supporters are loyal to their man and
they will crawl across broken glass to
vote for him they'll roll around in it
twice yes they'll be like if you want to
vote you got to roll back three three
times they'll be like I'll do four just
to to prove how much I really want to
vote for this guy and it's not just
about for Trump that's what the a lot of
media doesn't understand they're like
these people are cultists no that's how
much they just really hate you they are
they are sick of the establishment
corruption the media lies and it's not
about Trump it's about someone who will
finally just start telling them
off they love Trump they love Gates
because these people are fighting for
the American people they're just not
going along to get along there's a a
poll out from Yugo and it was sponsored
by The Economist and it has Joe Biden
with a 42% unfavorability rating I mean
wow he is not in a good position and
that's basically where his
unfavorability has hung
out presidency in aggregate it's 55 yeah
aggregate but Biden Biden's disapproval
right now is 55% I want everyone to
understand because we pulled this up
before the show for a reason currently
the latest poll shows that uh Gaza
supports Hamas
51% Joe Biden's support 41% Joe Biden
has less support in this country than
Hamas has among Palestinians and I'm not
I'm not saying that as it's not there's
no real political Point other than to
say people in Gaza support Hamas more
than we in the United States support Joe
Biden what that means this man goes on
TV and tells us he's going to be funding
all of these things and doing all these
things and we're the majority of the
country doesn't like it when these Hamas
terrorists come in Israel the majority
people there are in favor of what Hamas
is doing now I'm not trying to divert it
we'll go back to politics the point is
this just shows How Deeply unpopular Joe
Biden is I don't see I and I don't see
no he's deeply unpopular and people
don't trust him they think he's too old
I mean even before the disaster of the
last couple of weeks even without
Ukraine people were not enthusiastic
about him he was just the other option
and they were too scared of trump I
guess but in this case I think even
people who are scared of trump think he
know he would handle the geopolitical
situation better than bid I want to pull
go back to this average here the
aggregate shows uh messenger October 4th
through the 7th with a 56% disapproval
but if you go to the latest CB CBS News
has Biden's disapproval at 60% and his
approval is only at 40
now CNBC had him a week ago or or about
five days ago at 37% approval that's
what
I man I like 30 something that's
apocalyptic yeah when I hit 30 I was
like there's no way dude but but think
of this for a second I
mean I'm I'm not happy he's doing a
terrible job and I think his disapproval
shows the disastrous state of our
country but all these polls don't matter
unless people vote and make a difference
the fact of the matter is Democrats are
going to be getting ballots into boxes
despite his strong disapproval and that
means that we have to have a all of the
above approach to voting if we're going
to compete and have any semblance of a
chance of winning in 2024 so what's your
ideal scenario in that case I mean what
I'm building right now I launched an
organization early vote action.com in
response in part to 2022 guys we should
have had a red tsunami it should have
been a resounding defeat of the Dem rtic
party and we only took a majority in the
House of Representatives and we elected
John fedman to the United States pania
in Pennsylvania of all places but the
issue is because the Democrats and
establishment Republicans changed the
rules and the GOP overwhelmingly did not
adapt to those changes no they didn't
adapt and and so while the sentiment was
certainly there for the Republicans to
win they did not have the infrastructure
to to get those votes and are they just
not good at assembling the
infrastructure like what's your take on
why they failed to adapt I want to read
this real quick sorry just to interrupt
cuz you know with Biden giving his
speech earlier there's a tweet from RNC
Biden basically said we're going to war
with Russia and it it they're saying he
was misspeaking they're saying it was it
was it was an accident with a
teleprompter no but he says we'll have
we we will have something we do not seek
make it clear we do not seek we do not
seek to have American troops fighting in
Russia or fighting against
Russia he said we'll have that yeah and
so we can all just be like he's he's he
miss let me let me play the clip here
I'll just play the audio for you let me
uh he was very
clear and if Putin attacks a NATO Ally
we will defend every inch of NATO which
it treaty requires and calls for we'll
have something that we do not seek make
it clear we do not seek we do not seek
to have American troops fighting in
Russia or fighting against Russia I want
to stress um the full the full context
of that statement is we will be fighting
in Russia if they attack NATO M so you
know it looks like the RNC is trying to
make it seem like he misread the
prompter by saying we will have that no
he intended to say that we he to make it
clear this is not he he went back and
clarified what he meant just in case
anyone would question it later yeah we
don't want to go to war but we will have
that and the r is saying that he
misspoke yeah the RNC says Biden V
teleprompter like they're making it seem
like he misread it's like no he intended
to tell the American people that we will
be at war with and in Russia if if
Russia attacks NATO it's like gr's
actually on the RNC research account no
we do seek the war yeah sometimes it's
like it's bad that he misspoke and then
other times it's like oh he never
misspoke ever he's never said anything
wrong but then when it's when it's
convenient for him oh yeah guys he just
misspoke yeah every time so my favorite
is when the media translates for him oh
yeah the president said tremendously
intelligent things about the economy he
expressed his uh concern over rising
Rising costs and and low wages but you
would think think this kind of ambiguity
in Biden speech is another reason that
would turn people to the polls right I
mean there was that whole thing earlier
this week where he was like I never
thought I'd have to confirm you know
deceased children or whatever and then
it came out where the White House was
like oh no he didn't see the pictures
like it's not clear like I would not
want to be I do not want to be on the
brink of any kind of international
Skirmish especially on multiple fronts
with a guy who we have to immediately
clarify what he means this is not strong
leadership and I Can Only Imagine
that will drive voters to the polls
although to your point can Republicans
capitalize on it are you finding a lot
of people who are saying they aren't
going to vote anymore they don't trust
voting anymore I hear that I mean I
don't know if they mean it cuz I I mean
look I understand how people feel it's a
really emotional time I mean I think
everybody is literally angry at
everything right because it's not like
Republicans really have an answer right
now I mean with all due respect we don't
have the speakership because we can't
all coales and come together as a family
and do the right thing so I get it
everybody's just mad and yes I do hear
Scott it's rigged Scott it's the machine
Scott why should I vote I don't matter
but I mean look that's why I've been
working so hard this year and that's why
Louisiana was important I wanted to show
people we could do it we can win and
guess what we won early voting I push
people to early vote we lost last time
in 2019 when we lost the governor ship
it was 44% to 41 Dem this time it was
44% to 41 Republican we won early voting
we won on the day it didn't go to runoff
wow and so that's why I really wanted
people to know that have that win on
October 14th because it would Propel us
into November 7th and I found the runoff
thing really interesting because that
basically never happens in Louisiana
right they almost always end up in in R
called the the jungle primary jungle
primary there were 15 candidates 15 wow
and you would people like uh an elected
official Running as well and despite all
that Jeff lindry won with 51% of the
vote outright yeah so for for Jungle
primaries you have to get at least 50%
which means regularly there's no
outstanding candidate in Louisiana and
you you have changed changed the tide
there well well we did I mean there was
a lot of Sweat Equity from people all
across however I have I have been
pushing well he is a republican Jesus I
have been pushing this message of a
diverse approach to voting and all of
the above and I firmly believe I'm going
to say this if we wait to vote on one
day in November 2024 then Joe Biden is
getting reelected and everything that
you're seeing right now is only going to
be exacerbated so what does the strategy
look like going into Kentucky CU theirs
is coming up in a couple weeks maybe
November 7th well I have to say KY is
not looking so good right now guys and
this is consequential look we wish Mitch
mcell the best of health the best of
life for him and his family but his
health is in question according to law
if the current Democrat Governor uh sees
McConnell retire while he is Governor
he's the one that appoints a replacement
but that Democratic governor already
said that he will not follow the law so
to anybody that wants to defeat Joe
Biden and have a Republican senate
senate that will help our next candidate
our next Republican president then it
matters what happens this November with
that governor election it matters
electing a republican into office and
making sure that the Democrat is not the
one to appoint a replacement for mle
this is consequential before we jump to
the next St I just want to mention cuz
we we had we we started pretty quickly
with our intros for people who are
wondering what's up with the thumbnail
it's because initially Ashley wasn't
going to make it on time and uh the
train got delayed or whatever and so I
asked our graphic artist can you just
whip something up real quick just
whatever and this is what we got and
then Ashley did make it on time but was
doing her hair or something when we were
setting up the show and I was like nope
this this the drawing's going in it was
meant to be it looks just like me thank
you it it kind of does you know as far
as stick figures go I have to close one
of my eyes halfway for it to wear like
twist it and I didn't realize it was a
drawing the difference thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net out and we'll see you all
next
time